hi
uh good evening everyone i'm priyana
tarajan the current director of the
frankie program
i'm an astrophysicist and i'm a faculty
member in the departments of physics and
astronomy at yale
i am deeply invested in
interdisciplinary scholarship as you've
probably guessed
and thanks to my academic training um in
um sort of an intellectual interest in
the history and philosophy of science
i'm very fortunate to be leading the
frankie program which is the flagship
cross-disciplinary program at
yale first i would like to start by
recognizing the generosity and support
of our benefactors
mr and mrs richard and barbara frankie
for all they do for us
and for yale i'm delighted uh that they
are going to be joining us today
uh first i would also like to remind you
to that we are recording this event
and that all participants must therefore
mute their videos
if you wish you can submit your
questions after
the talk through the chat feature our
speaker this evening
is one of our own brilliant scholars
professor alan mchale
professor of history and the current
chair of the department of history at
yale
um allen is a preeminent historian of
the early modern muslim world
the ottoman empire and egypt his
research and teaching
focuses mostly on the history of empires
and
environments both matters that are
incredibly important to understand
beyond the confines of academia as we
all
venture to make sense of today's complex
globally interconnected and yet
fractured world
rife with inequities of opportunity
health and wealth
and the looming climate catastrophe
brought by uncurtailed human activities
over history and their damaging impact
on the environment
he received his phd from the university
of california berkeley
where his dissertation won the malcolm
care award of the middle east studies
association
and berkeley's own james kettner award
he was a member of the andrew mellon
fellowship of scholars in the humanities
and was at stanford university before
coming to yale in 2010
he's the author of many acclaimed books
um
uh the first of which the animal in
ottoman egypt came out in 2014
nature and empire in ottoman egypt and
environmental history that came out in
2011
he's also the editor of water on sand
environmental histories of the middle
east and north africa
so his articles research articles have
appeared in
all the eminent journals um across
disciplines and he's the recipient of
many awards and honors and interest of
time
i will just mention a few the roger owen
award of the middle east studies
association
the alice hamilton price of the american
society for environmental history
the wayne room susan rasmussen price uh
of the agricultural history society and
the uh yale's gustav rannis and samuel
and ronnie heyman prizes
he teaches undergraduate and graduate
courses uh in the history of the early
modern
early modern muslim world and the
mediterranean the ottoman empire
and environmental history so before i
hand over
to him i just wanted to remind you of a
few upcoming frankie program events
we have uh the author and science
communicator
uh anissa ramirez former yale faculty
member giving a talk
on april 20th at 4 pm and
we have the inference project colloquium
by the philosopher lorenzo mangani
on april 22nd and then we have
linda lynn hopped the author of mozart
starling who will be speaking to us on
april 27th
so we have a full roster for uh april
and we also have uh are planning to show
the movie coded bias
and have a discussion with the filmmaker
on april 21st
and so i would also like to remind you
all to
look at our two other ongoing projects
the learning by doing project
on our website and the inference
understanding the nature of inference uh
project so
now to uh today's event today alan will
be talking to us
about his new book god's shadow sultan
saleem his ottoman empire and the making
of the modern world
and the title of his talk is columbus
and islam
and this is an encounter that i'm
extremely excited and curious to hear
about
thank you so much alan for agreeing to
speak to us today
thank you priya uh very much for having
me um
i i want to begin by extending my thanks
to you for the invitation
uh to uh tai and to guy for helping to
organize today's event
um thanks to everybody for tuning in
on this afternoon in march um i wish we
could do it in person but uh one day
one day soon um i'm gonna go ahead and
begin
by sharing my screen
and as i do that um of course allow me
also
to thank um the frankie family for um
for this uh this lecture series and for
all of their uh support of what we do
at yale um so
um as as priya said this talk is coming
out of a book
that i um just published that's really
focused on the life
of um a particular ottoman sultan
um saleem the first the ninth sultan of
the ottoman empire
who lives from 1470 to 1520. i'm really
not going to be talking much about him
today
i'm going to be focusing in on a part of
the book that addresses
part of the role of the ottoman empire
and
of other muslim polities around the
mediterranean in the shaping of columbus
this is something that i go to
go um in depth um into
in the book um so if you if you're
curious about
how this story fits into a larger story
about
the ottoman empire um and the early
modern world
uh i'd encourage you um to take a look
at the book
so um two narratives dominate the story
of the conjoining
of the continents of the old world and
uh the americas
peopling and de-peopling that is
conquest and genocide
nation-building and colonization the
migration of europeans
and the forced movement of enslaved
africans on the one hand
and the displacement and death of
millions of indigenous americans on the
other
these are obviously very familiar
narratives narratives that
work quite well um much of the arc of
the story that they tell
is um useful for us in thinking about
uh the history of the atlantic world and
much of it
does a lot of very good work um for our
understanding
of how we came to be in this historical
moment
as with any historical framework though
these grand narratives
also miss some things as well so in my
talk today i want to argue for
another brand narrative one that i think
needs to be a part
of the violent story of the joining of
the four atlantic
continents um and that is the role of
the confrontation between islam and
christendom
in the shaping of this history it's an
essential part of the story i'll try to
show today
it says an essential part of the story
of the colonization of the americas
um the extension of europe and africa
across
the ocean um and it's essential
that it'd be a part of our understanding
of this history
conflict and cooperation between islam
and christianity
shaped the history of the mediterranean
perhaps more
than any other single force and this was
as true uh before 1492
as it was after some of which is
gestured
to in the quote that's on the screen
the europeans who went to the americas
were in many ways formed
by this geopolitical encounter and as
i'll discuss it remained a salient
feature of their world
even on the other side of the ocean
indeed one could tell a continuous story
of the role of islam
in the shaping of the history of the
americas from 1492
to the present this is a story that
involves
slavery piracy trade
the captivity of europeans in the muslim
world
immigration warfare cultural exchange
and assimilation i won't be able to tell
that full story here today rather
i'm focusing obviously on the very first
moment
of this history the one that has rightly
been freighted with so much explanatory
weight in the
in the narratives i mentioned above
columbus and 1492.
i will ask how islam shaped columbus and
his voyages
and what its role was in the very early
years of the european
colonization of the caribbean this will
be the bulk of my talk
today and at the end i'll offer thoughts
about
some of the implications of the story
that i'm telling about columbus
and islam so let me begin
uh the story then where um columbus
began
and that is in the city of genoa
he was born there in 1450
and even in the small neighborhood he
shared with his parents
and four siblings islam was a presence
columbus spent most of the first two
decades of his life in that neighborhood
he would have seen or heard about the
many fleets leaving for jerusalem
on one of the numerous crusades that
originated in genoa
columbus's city was a magnet for
crusaders owing to the strong
presence of the knights of saint john
who offered
free housing and medical care to
crusaders
columbus and his family likely knew some
crusaders
and he no doubt grew up hearing of their
uh tales of distant lands and infidel
enemies
it's important that columbus was born
just two years before the ottoman
sultan mehmet the conqueror took the
city of
constantinople this is the bellini
portrait of mehmet more than any other
event
this conquest shaped the contours of
columbus's
and indeed his entire generation's
geopolitical life
constant calls for european crusades
against the ottomans
um didn't lead to very much in the
second half of the 15th century
columbus's age was mostly one of
european stasis
in the face of muslim ascendancy
in genoa's san lorenzo cathedral
columbus went to mass every week this
church held
important treasures supposedly captured
during earlier crusades
an emerald green bowl said to be the
dish jesus washed his hands in before
the last supper
and a silver reliquary purported to
contain the ashes of john the baptist
such trophies of conquest were sprinkled
all over europe from the smallest towns
to the largest cathedrals
they brought the conflict between islam
and christianity into nearly every
european neighborhood church amulets of
the looming threat of islam
that had supposedly been captured during
earlier
crusades in between sundays at
san lorenzo columbus would have learned
about other europeans
who had traveled to the muslim world
even though it was a vital crusader
entrepreneur
genoa was above all a mercantile port
not a military one
over the centuries the genoese merchant
families who ran the city developed many
distant connections colonies colonies of
genoese merchants prospered in cities
like beirut
alexandria tunis oron algiers
in europe in places like naples paris
london and so on sometimes these
genoese trading families even exercised
something akin to political control
in some of these cities especially
around
the black sea coast genoa maintained
very old connections to ports and towns
ports and towns that would steadily be
incorporated into the ottoman empire in
the 14th
and the 15th centuries in columbus's
youth
genoa's merchant community was growing
indeed quite anxious about ottoman
advances
in the black sea and the mediterranean
and already
mourning some of their losses around the
two seas
in addition thailand yes i had a very
quick question
so was genoa actually a very wealthy
city at this point
or i mean so what was the socio-economic
frame
at this time sure genoa is is indeed
quite quite a wealthy city
um um largely based on its trading
connections with the east
absolutely um
and you get a sense from this map of the
expanse of their
of their trading connections um
so in addition to breathing in the the
mercantile air all around him in genoa
columbus learned important lessons um
about the east by
reading uh the works of various
writers and in particular the work of
one
other italian who had spent time in some
of genoa's
black sea cities and that's marco polo
reading the famous tales of marco polo
and again other accounts of travels to
distant
lands helped to form columbus's mental
canvas as a boy
one of the most important things
columbus learned from marco polo
was the existence of a figure known as
the grand con
of the east marco supposedly arrived
in the opulent court of this grand con
far off in some vague place in asia
past constantinople jerusalem baghdad
and afghanistan where he writes that he
discovered a jewel encrusted paradise of
luxury learning and power
what most interested columbus and other
european readers of marco polo
um was that the grand con uh was
precisely
not a christian but according to marco
polo
wanted to be one he had achieved the
heights of civilization without the
benefits of christianity
the gran khan seemed to understand the
truth of the religion
and might even convert himself thereby
gaining
uh for christianity the souls of all his
subjects
this fantasy of the grand khan and his
potential conversion
lit european uh imaginations for
christians
he offered the perfect mirror of
everything islam should have been but
wasn't
a civilization no doubt one formed
outside of the realm of christianity
but one that also recognized its own
bankruptcy in the face of the glories of
christianity
the gran khan was thus not yet a
christian but according to the fantasy
was always about
to be one moreover once he entered the
faith
the muslims of the middle east in
possession of jerusalem the object of
the crusades
would then be surrounded by christians
who in one
final apocalyptic pincer move would
destroy
islam forever to retake the holy city
so after centuries of crusades with the
spectacular growth of the ottoman and
mamluk empires
increasingly blocking access to trade
with the east
europe looked with anticipation to a
potentate
thousands of miles away
filled with these and other fantasies
raised on
accounts of the crusades columbus's
interactions with islam
deepened during his teenage years when
he began taking
to the mediterranean as an apprentice
sailor embarking on his first maritime
voyages
at the age of 13 or 14.
he worked as a merchant's assistant um
packing merchandise on board ships
recording weights
and costs securing lodging in
ports for captain and crew and generally
being available
to help with navigation and business
matters
he built a reputation for himself as a
reliable
and efficient sailor for hire and was
able to find
endless opportunities working the sea
for merchant
and um other expeditions in the employ
of europe's many small principalities
and larger
polities some of these voyages
um in his um in his early years sailing
around the mediterranean
took him to the shores of both the
ottoman empire
and to other muslim states around the
sea
so um the map that i'm now showing you
um is is one that we're quite accustomed
to seeing
about um columbus's um
um sailing career before the four
voyages
that he was plying off the course of
portugal
made his way down um to west africa
which i'll talk about
in a moment um but the the the section
that i'm about to share with you is
really even before this
um it's to make the point that he had a
mediterranean
um sailing career before ever crossing
through the strait of gibraltar um and
that this is an important part
of understanding columbus and his
biography um but but really crucial for
understanding his connections
um with the muslim world so um i don't
have a map
of his mediterranean voyages um but the
map that i'm showing you now um has a
pre-map
that i'm i'm gonna give to you now in in
words
so in 1472 when columbus was 21
we we have his first uh we have an
account of his first direct encounter
with the muslim world the first one that
we know he took a job as a mercenary
um sailor for the king of honju
during a war to capture naples
over the course of this fighting one of
the king's large
three masted ships was captured and
commandeered
to tunis in north africa the king
dispatched columbus to sail to north
africa
to bring his ship back tunis in those
years
was uh the stronghold of the hafsid
empire
um an empire that ruled um along much of
the coast of
uh north africa that made much of its
money from
piracy and and also from the overland um
caravan
trade along the coast and then also
along the sahara
like other city-states around the
mediterranean whether um in
in italy or other parts of north africa
um the hafzan empire
made um a lot of money um and was able
to put that money towards great
um art culture and patronage
intrepid youth that he was columbus
uh charged with retrieving uh the king's
ship
sailed um excitedly he tells us
with his more apprehensive crew from
naples
first to sardinia to rest and resupply
and then turn south to north africa
to attempt to retrieve the ship we don't
know the outcome
of this venture we don't know if the
ship was retrieved or not
columbus doesn't mention that he
retrieved the ship one might
presume that if he had he would have
mentioned it um despite the
uncertainties though in the historical
record
this earliest encounter of columbus with
the world of islam
was his first opportunity to test um
the stories that he had heard about um
in his youth about
crusades uh the stories he heard at
church from reading marco polo
his first opportunity to test these
stories against the reality
of the awesome power of a muslim state
in this case the hafzah empire
he experienced firsthand uh the naval
power
of the rulers of tunis to capture and
hold
the king's ship his account
um that he writes um after the fact
um um describes the fear that he saw in
his crew's
eyes when they realized they would have
to sail south
into enemy territory um presumably
outmatched
and outmanned sailing to tunis
um in his early 20s thus was an
opportunity to test the mythologies of
his youth
um against the power of
muslim states around the mediterranean
he would gain closer and much more
profound first-hand experience of the
muslim world
a couple years later when in
1475 a family firm in genoa the spinolas
sent him to kios the hilly island of
mostly scrub
vegetation in the aegean sea
just off the anatolian shore kiosks
famous for its mastic this is the mastic
tree and then the mastic sap
that was used in cooking um and
medicines of all kinds
genoa lost um um its
colony in crimea in the northern black
sea
its last outpost on the black sea
in 1475 just a few months in fact before
columbus
went to kiosks that year so kiosks when
columbus
arrived there represented genoa's
easternmost territory um and
in in the mediterranean and the black
sea and was therefore a vital
uh commercial and um strategic
interests this is a rendition of the
port of kiosk
in traveling uh to kiosks columbus was
exposed for the very first time
to the awesome power of the ottoman
empire
although the island was still a genoese
colony it was very much
in the ottomans orbit they ruled the
blue seas around the island
and all the ports of call on the coast
just across the narrow straits
that separated the island from mainland
and atoya
the ottomans had captured other major
aegean islands over the previous two
decades
places like embros
and columbus was regaled um when in
kiosk
with tales of dread and horror about the
ottoman
conquest of kafa in crimea again
just a few months before he arrived
there and even more so
of the conquest of constantinople almost
two decades
earlier the memory of the loss of
constantinople
in particular was very fresh on the
island
of kios even over 20 years later
the genoese sent many reinforcements
from kiosk
the closest of the italian states
outposts
to constantinople and this contingent
suffered
heavy losses that affected almost every
family
on kiosk so the stories columbus learned
in his youth
of christianity's crusades with islam
were suddenly brought to life for him
when he met and heard from the relatives
of others who had actually
fought against the awesome power of the
ottomans
in their conquest of constantinople
here on the eastern front of christendom
he witnessed the awesome power of the
ottoman empire
he saw that it surrounded a tiny island
like
kiosk that it might very well continue
its its march
west um perhaps even into europe itself
like other islands the majority of
kiosks
was greek but there was a growing
turkish population
there as well columbus heard
on the island about um constantinople
and other losses around uh the black sea
and
in the aegean bringing home to him again
the idea that christianity had to be
boldly offensive
against islam or risk
further losses to the ottomans and other
muslim powers after his time
in the employ of the spinolas and his
time
in kiosk columbus eventually makes his
way to portugal
there he fell in with uh the
group of explorers that the famous uh
portuguese prince henry the navigator
had assembled before his death like many
ambitious europeans
these portuguese adventurers were
looking for ways
around the muslim world they also
believed in the truth of crusade
um like columbus they had heard tales of
the grand con of the east
um and were interested in trying to find
a path
towards uh towards the grand con
they were indeed quite explicit in
defining um
many of their expeditions in religious
terms
as part of a global crusade between
christendom
and islam for example according to one
of henry's contemporaries
writing in that faithful fateful year of
1453 henry
was actuated by the zeal for god by the
desire for alliance with the eastern
christians of the grand khan
by an eagerness to know how far the
power of the infidel
existed by the wish to convert people to
christianity
and by the desire to fight the moors
henry's most famous plan to outflank
the muslims of the mediterranean rested
on his belief in a southern
route around africa um and and he and
his explorers
spent much of their time flying around
along the west african coast it was to
their utter
terror and dismay when working their way
south along the african coast
they discovered that islam was already
flourishing
in many parts of west africa
by the time the portuguese arrived islam
had grown from a minority faith of a few
adherents to the official state religion
of several
west african empires most prominent
among them
the mali empire that had adopted islam
as its official religion in
1324.
in the 15th century when these
portuguese explorers were
sailing along the coast the presence of
muslims in west africa
further deepened the sense among
european christian
christian crusaders that their faith was
somehow surrounded
by islam and that some drastic action
was needed
to attempt to defend against this
further spread as they continued sailing
south along the african coast the
farthest
point they reached was the port city of
sao jorge de mena what is known today as
el mina in ghana this city would
prove a linchpin of portugal's empire in
west africa
a key conduit for funneling first gold
and later slaves from west africa
to portugal and then eventually
elsewhere as well
in 1481 portugal's new king
zhao ii resolved that his kingdom needed
a stronger presence on the gulf of
guinea
to protect its growing economic stakes
in the gold trade
and so he dispatched a heavily armed
fleet
with building materials to this trading
post of sao jorge
de mena to construct a
um a fortress um on 10 caravels and two
transport ships
um foundation stones roof tiles nails
provisions all were sent and and the
structure that was constructed
was one of the first european um um
buildings uh constructed in sub-saharan
africa
of course many men were sent um on
these 12 ships to help with the
construction and
to deal with any business matters and
columbus
was on one of these 12 ships now
30 years old when he arrives in
el mina columbus brings together
three pieces of very crucial information
that
concretized the idea that he had been
thinking about for quite a while now
the idea of a western route to
asia in west africa he found
seemingly endless supplies of precious
gold
the gold coast contemporary
understandings of geography
taught columbus that regions at the same
latitude enjoyed similar climates
and and natural features so in his
understanding
if he was to head directly due west from
elena
he would find lands rich in gold gold
was important to him
uh to help to build the army that he
needed
for the reconquest of jerusalem
the second piece of information that
columbus um uh
learned in elmina was that asia was
close
sailors in the african city told him
that logs
regularly washed up on shore that seemed
to have been worked by human hands
evidence um that the lands across the
ocean from once
this worked wood supposedly came could
not have been
very far away at all
the third piece of information that um
he learned in el mina had to do
with um the atlantic's currents
and wind patterns the prevailing um
current off the west african coast flows
out to sea
which is the exact opposite of the
situation in portugal
where the eastward currents made it
difficult to sell west for most of the
year
so to head west from iberia then it made
sense to first sail
south along the african coast to pick up
the westerly current across the ocean
from el mina columbus returned to iberia
confident that he understood now how to
execute
his plan to sail across um
um uh the ocean uh to find asia
the grand khan to surround the muslims
of the middle east
and eventually to conquer jerusalem
the thing that he most needed at this
point was a patron
the story of columbus is back and forth
negotiations between
various um european sovereigns uh
to secure patronage is a very very
famous one that i won't um
get into um now
what i want to emphasize though and what
has not been um
remarked upon is uh the role that the
ottomans
and and other muslims played in this
affair of seeking patronage
columbus's major push for the money that
he needed for his voyages
um occurred during the late 1480s
this was the same decade in which the
eventual financiers of his voyages the
second cousins isabella and ferdinand
um had declared their war against islam
in iberia and it's not a coincidence
that europe's war on islam in iberia and
elsewhere
and columbus's voyages occurred at
almost exactly the same time
in columbus's mind in the mind of the
spanish sovereigns
these were two pieces of what they
interpreted as a millennial war
between christianity and islam as part
of a global strategy against islam the
spanish moved their navies east in the
mediterranean
against the ottomans and other muslim
powers endeavored to push out
all of iberia's muslims and sent
columbus off
um to the west um to try to surround the
muslims of the middle east
ottoman advances in the second half of
the 15th century
directly impacted spanish holdings in
the mediterranean
mehmet the conqueror the conqueror of
constantinople
captured the strategic strategic walled
port city
of otranto on the very tip
of the heel of the italian peninsula
right
here or toronto he captured um
this this small port in 1480
from there he sent ships
to the coast of sicily to assess a
potential invasion of
that island sicily is the largest of the
mediterranean's island once a muslim
possession of course
um but in the 15th century was under the
nominal
sovereignty of ferdinand and isabella of
spain
and so a threatening move by the
ottomans
demanded the spanish king and queen's
attention
ottoman rule over a place like sicily
would have solidified their control of
the entire eastern half of the
mediterranean
again think of genoa being pushed out of
the black sea
being steadily pushed out of the aegean
and now the ottomans pushing even
further west
potentially all the way to sicily uh
were the ottomans to hold sicily this
would give them a launching pad for
invasions further west
um in the ceasesly is very much uh the
midway point
um of the sea um and and was of much
concern
uh um of the of the ottoman of the
spanish sovereigns
um so much so that one of isabella's um
court chroniclers um
wrote um quote every day news came to
the king and queen
that the turks had a great armada on the
sea
and that they were sending it to conquer
the kingdom of sicily
the spanish sovereigns leapt into action
um sending a fleet to defend
um sicily luckily for them though mehmet
died the next year in 1481 and the
ottoman
succession crisis um forced the empire
to give up
um on sicily um to give up otronto
and indeed to withdraw from italy
altogether
um and they would never gain any other
territory um on the italian peninsula
um after that despite this retreat
though
um over the course of the 1480s the
ottomans continued to push west
in the mediterranean testing spain's
resolve and the resolve
of other european powers in 1488
mehmet's son and successor bayazet
attacked malta this prompted spain again
to send reinforcements to strengthen its
garrisons in sicily again malta very
close to sicily as you see here
between 1487 and the middle of the 1490s
ottoman ships made landings even further
west reaching all the way to corsica
pisa the balearic islands and
north african ports just across from the
iberian
mainland itself these were not full
scale military invasions
did not result in any sort of lasting
ottoman
settlements but nevertheless the site of
ottoman ships
forcibly pulling in to harbor panicked
um already frightened um european
states the force of the ottomans seemed
to be all over
the sea these gains in the mediterranean
against spain and other
european interests made the already
precarious
position of spain's muslims much more
dire
these internal muslims in iberia were
lumped together with spain's external
muslim enemies
like columbus henry the pope isabella
considered it her duty to crusade
against muslims wherever
they may be within iberia there were
muslims both
living under spanish christian rule and
small
muslim states um in the south
independent states
in the south both were liable
um allies of the ottomans and other
muslims according to isabella
and ferdinand so given the ottomans
territorial expansion in the 1480s
isabella and ferdinand saw their
reconquista in the south
their war against the muslims in the
south not simply
as a process of local political
consolidation
on the iberian peninsula but rather as
one piece of what they saw as a global
civilizational war
interpreted by them and by other
christians as the first step
in rolling back islam and its
representative states
from the mediterranean and if they had
their way
eventually from the face of the earth
altogether
steeped his entire life in the rhetoric
and reality of the crusades
columbus used his belief in the notion
of a war between
christendom and islam to push his case
for the atlantic voyages with isabella
and ferdinand
if he could show them that heading west
across the ocean would help to defeat
islam
then he thought they might be more
liable to finance
his journey columbus found it very
difficult to get any traction
with the sovereigns in this period they
were really too busy
with their wars to pay him any attention
um
in the late 1480s um
ferdinand and isabella were fighting in
the south
and the reconquista was quite successful
in these
in these years the famous
surrender of granada of course on
january
2nd 1492 legally ended
over seven centuries of muslim rule on
the iberian peninsula
for christians everywhere not just in
spain granada represented a monumental
victory over islam
church bells rang out across european
cities
the pope ordered a day of festivities
celebratory
bullfights were organized across spain
mock reenactments of the siege of
granada
uh were played out across um european
towns
coming just a few decades after the loss
of constantinople
granada was for many in europe an act of
retribution
a christian answer to the most powerful
muslim empire
on earth in the words of one spanish
court historian
the conquest of granada was famed and
celebrated through all the realms of
christendom
and it extended to the farthest and most
remote lands of the turk
and the sultan
after the fall of granada in january
1492
isabella against the judgment of her
advisors and her husband emboldened by
her recent victories
agreed to fund columbus's journey across
the atlantic
she had just vanquished spain's
muslim kingdoms a first step she thought
um in her global uh war against
christianity's
ultimate enemy christ would march up
upon the world jerusalem would be one
if columbus is planned risky and
far-fetched
as it was could contribute in even a
minor way
um to the destruction of islam then it
would have proved more
than a worthy investment of the queen's
resources
the opening lines of columbus's logbook
on his first foray across the atlantic
make plain that he understood his voyage
as a new crusade
in in centuries of war between islam and
christendom
in the space of just a single sentence
columbus pivoted from spain's
reconquista
to finding and converting the grand con
marco polo
had promised um and
to surrounding therefore um um
islam the extension of spain's
civilizational religious crusade is part
of what sent columbus off across the
atlantic
and this is essential to understanding
his voyages
he sailed off to when jerusalem um he
sailed off
uh to win jerusalem for christendom
and this is why the story that i've
relayed to you of the biography of
columbus's interactions with islam
matters so much from his earliest days
in genoa
where he waved good tidings to crusaders
to his experience with
the portuguese enslavement of muslims
and others in west africa
to the very moment before he left europe
in granada
columbus's life was formed in and
against
islam so this brings us then to that
fateful
moment to 1492 that freighted a tipping
point
of multi-continental destruction and
transformation
it also brings me to stop sharing my
screen
what does the history um i've just
relayed of columbus and islam
mean for our understanding of this
faithful fateful year
when turning to the writings of columbus
and others in that first
generation of conquistadors one finds
perhaps
surprisingly sparks of islam flying up
from their pages in the americas where
islam so very clearly
did not exist they nevertheless saw it
as arresting as it may seem the spanish
stretched the analytical limits of their
late 15th century universe
to understand some of the americas and
its indigenous peoples
as somehow related to islam
what do i mean by this let me let me
give some examples
um in his um journals columbus refers
to the weapons of the indigenous tainos
in the caribbean as el fantes
a spanish word derived from the arabic
for a curved
metal sword inscribed with quranic
verses
that was commonly used by muslim
soldiers in battle
in in spain despite the fact
that columbus himself tells us that the
taino quotes
have no iron and of course they knew
nothing of the quran
he likens them to muslim soldiers by
putting
these swords in his hands in their hands
sorry
um later when columbus first saw the
scarves of a group
of taino women he thought they were
somehow related
through trade or some other form of
eurasian contact
to what he termed moorish sashes
a friar named ramon pane who sailed on
columbus's
second voyage in 1494
described indian singing as akin
to that of the moors a couple decades
later
cortes wrote that the aztecs of mexico
quote war moorish robes that aztec
women quote looked like moorish women
aztec dancing he thought was derived
from the dances
of the moors cortez's encounter with the
aztecs proved especially fertile
for these kinds of comparisons between
the islam islamic civilizations the
spanish
um had fought in the old world and what
they were experiencing in the new world
in the aztecs cortez and his men met a
formidable
complex empire with enormous cities one
of the largest cities in the world at
the time
a highly sophisticated political culture
and imposing armies
more than for example uh taino society
the spanish saw in the aztecs a rival
enemy civilization
akin to their enemies of the old world
uh the muslim empires of the
mediterranean
cortez wrote for example that he saw
over 400 mosques
mesquitas in what is today mexico
he called montezuma a sultan he
described montezuma's palaces in terms
strikingly similar to those of the
muslim palaces
of granada including claiming to see in
mexico
tiles and roofing that only existed
in granada at the time these things
continued long after
columbus and cortez over the course of
the 16th century
the spanish for example would try to
subdue and convert
the nomadic chichamecas of mexico
referring to to them as an arabes the
arabs in brazil the children of
portuguese men
and indian women were referred to as el
mamalucos
the mamluks the mammook empire based in
cairo
plains indians captured and transported
by the spanish as
slaves um to what is today new mexico
came to be known as
henasarios a corruption of the turkish
word for the janissaries
yenice the spanish named a large city
in the yucatan grand cairo um we could
go on and on
citing these kinds of examples the city
on the on the u.s mexico border today
that's that's in the news because of
the migrant crisis is another example of
this matamoros
more slayer the slayer of the moors
at one level there's nothing surprising
about any of this
the spanish conquistadors were forged in
an old world crucible of christian
muslim
violence many of them had fought against
the muslim kingdoms of southern liberia
and north africa many had encountered
muslims
in west africa as well many had
traded with muslim traders in ports
around the mediterranean
grasping for some conceptual framework
through which to reconcile
all of the difference and the newness
they encountered in the americas
they turned to the most extreme version
of otherness available
to them islam in a new place
fighting new enemies they fell back on
what they knew
as we always do as john elliott one of
the foremost historians of cortez
notes quote since the only political
moder
model for his conquest cortes knew was
the reconquest the reconquista
montezuma had to be treated in his
narrative as a muslim ruler would have
been
an ahuak in central mexico is thus
described as far as cortez is able
in images more appropriate to assyria or
persia
than to any possible american indian
society
at another level though the sparks of
islam in the historical record
of the early spanish colonial caribbean
offer us numerous ways
of conceiving of the place of islam in
the early modern world
and allow us to see the history of the
americas in a new way
and and these are going to be my my
closing my closing thoughts on these
two points columbus's biography
with islam helps us to see that 1492
was not the break it's often portrayed
to be
1492 the beginning of the modern world
1492 the end of the independent
sovereignty
the americas to properly and fully
understand 1492
we must understand the continuities that
made and shaped it
columbus's voyages across the atlantic
were a
direct result of one particular
continuity
that of muslim christian animosity in
the mediterranean
the crucible of the crusades centuries
of warfare
and the increasing encroachment of the
ottomans west in the years
after 1453 forged in the minds of
columbus
cortez and thousands of other europeans
that their enemies were muslims that the
notion of enemy
to them had something to do with islam
they took this long history of warring
with them across
the atlantic indeed many of those who
ended up fighting the american indians
in the new world had fought muslims in
the old world
some of them would even come back from
the americas to fight again
against their muslim enemies of old
cortez for example waged the last war of
his life
in algiers in 1541 after
his exploits in mexico as one of the
earliest
16th century spanish historians of the
americas wrote
quote the conquest of the indians began
after that of the moors was completed
so that the spaniards would ever fight
the infidels
islam had pushed europe's crusades to
the caribbean
where even on the other side of the
atlantic europeans
still often conceived of their enemies
as somehow
being related to muslims
in narratives of 1492 as break
islam is always portrayed as being of
the old world
part of all that was left behind for a
new
european beginning in a new world
it is precisely because islam was so
central
to the history of europe in the old
world that it had to be excised
from the histories of europe in the new
world
historians have in many ways followed
the lead of
many of these early europeans who went
to the americas
those who sought to relegate islam to
the past in favor
of the future free of this old world
menace
indeed beginning just a few decades
after columbus
and continuing for centuries after that
europeans feared the transfer
of islam to the americas trying to keep
islam
out of the new world meant also trying
to keep it out of many of the narratives
of the making of the modern world after
1492.
if the atlantic voyages are so crucial
to the history of the world
after the year 1500 i think it's hard to
argue
that they're not important and if islam
is
removed from this story then islam is
never
foundational additive or even relevant
to this modern history it stands apart
only appearing every now and then as a
violent
enemy on the margins leaving out the
story of islam
in the shaping of columbus thus removes
it from
the early history of the colonization of
the americas
it prevents us from seeing the integral
role islam played
in forming the violent early years of
spanish rule in the new world
however if we accept that islam
is part of one of the oldest cultural
tropes
in the new world as long as
the history of european colonialism and
disease in the americas
if we accept that islam was the mold
that cast the history of european
racial and ethnic thinking in the
americas as well as the history of
warfare
in the western hemisphere then we must
admit
that islam has to be a part of any
understanding
of the history of the americas from the
very beginning
the idea of islam as a deep existential
threat
was there at the beginning of europeans
stepping foot
on these continents vi the history of
this idea in the western
hemisphere is older than say
protestantism
or any british or french interests in
the americas
it's older than the transatlantic slave
trade
it's older than any nation state in the
americas
it runs through all of these histories
though and so beginning a history
of the americas here tells very
different stories
than those were used to indeed we might
go so far as to say
that the two origins of european
colonization in the americas
were its crusading ethos of the kind
that i've described today
and of course the deadly confrontations
with
native americans and these are linked
stories
as i've tried to suggest today telling
them
together allows us to uncover
a durable conceptual link in the
european turned american psyche
between violence against native
americans and muslims
if the original language of european
warfare
in this hemisphere derived from europe's
wars with islam
from at least the 18th century that
language was formed by america's warfare
against native peoples this is a
historical reversal
of profound importance that suggests
that we should spend more time
recognizing and thinking about the
history of these seemingly disparate
yet bound cultures moreover given that
since vietnam
the primary theater of american war has
been in the muslim world
with the attendant consequences for
muslim americans
it bears thinking deeply about this long
intertwined history of warfare
animosity and vilification
so this is admittedly a very long way
from where we've
where we've been i raise it though um
because some of the strands of our
present
were spun by the story of columbus and
islam that i presented
today it's an obvious starting point for
the history of how
european colonialism affected the
americas
and i've tried to suggest that um it's
also a starting point for thinking about
how native peoples
have been folded in to a long history of
european
islamic relations and this is a history
i think we need to assimilate
better doing so would help to contribute
to the manifold efforts to understand
histories of european
native encounters um and the histories
of
european polities in in the americas and
then eventually the united states itself
in a far more global scope
so i will end there thank you for your
attention and i really look forward um
to your
comments and questions thank you very
much
thank you alan for that wonderful talk
and
uh contextualization um i think there
are lots of
questions that we are getting on the
chat
but um i'm burning to ask
this question which is um
you know um the
where do where uh do
the jewish where does the jewish
expulsion and where do the jewish
peoples
come in this mix of this encounter
do you see them somehow
as being part or embroiled in this
and also what i'm really curious is you
know it's
when i want to feel optimistic it's hard
at the current moment
uh given um the global alignment
and these sort of animosities persistent
animosities
i love how you've drawn sort of
connected the dots
and shown that the sort of um animosity
towards others um has a very
long history and a very deep history um
um so it's curious you know if you think
about al andalus right there was this
moment golden moment when these multiple
cultures
thrived so do you what do you think
was uh key for that kind of
thriving of these multiple
religious traditions and cultures
thank you for that um yes so i didn't
have time
um to go into the the the history of
uh the jews of spain um is a really
important and integral part to this
story
um i can answer it in a couple of ways
um
so one is the you know the major events
of 1492 related to
iberia are the reconquista um columbus's
voyages and the expulsion of the jews
um i talked about two of them um in
um you know there's an ottoman part to
that story which is that
um most of um iberia's jews eventually
end up
in or more than any other single place
most of them end up in the ottoman
empire
um eventually this is after some time in
portugal or in north africa
or in various parts of of the
mediterranean but many eventually make
their way to the ottoman empire
um and famously the city of salonika
thessaloniki in today's greece
um becomes the largest jewish city in
the world um and at various points has a
jewish
majority so the first jewish majority
city
many did go to italy as well right yes
yes
um they're they're what they're there
are waves of
of um embarkations and expulsions um so
sometimes people settle in various
places and then
um and stay some people settle for a
little while and then move on
it's a very complicated a very
complicated history obviously
um um but in broad brush strokes
that's that's part of the that's part of
the story that i tell in my book and
that's part of the story here
there is it just and of course obviously
anti-judaism anti-semitism
um is is is rampant in spain
um before this period very famously the
um you know there are instances of of
um waves of anti-jewish violence um for
for centuries but but increasingly up to
1492.
um the the sort of catholic animosity
towards jews and muslims is quite
different
um in its nature um in the case of
muslims
it is more geopolitical
um and existential um
in the case of jews it's more
theological and at the level of
um of uh notions
of um cleanliness disease
um um um contagion
in cities right um um and
you know as i think you you were
suggesting i mean
linking others to disease is is
something that
that happens in spain in this period as
it is happening today
um um but it's because
there's no equivalent of a jewish
ottoman empire there is no
external jewish state that um
it is a potential geopolitical rival of
of a catholic state
and so so that makes the position of for
and there are other reasons obviously of
jews and muslims very different in spain
so this notion that
um the muslims of spain are a liable
fifth column
for any muslim polity whether it be the
ottomans the man looks et cetera
um is is one that doesn't exist for for
jews and so that gives a very different
positionality
of those communities um within spain
um thank you very much so um
i think i'll handle a couple of the
questions and ty then uh you can take
over
absolutely so yeah so there's a question
uh
from carlton tucker besides marco polo's
writings and crusades oral stories
would columbus have possibly heard of
the stories of idna batuta
some have called the muslim refer to him
as the muslim columbus
a century earlier um
yeah well the muslim marco polo not the
muslim columbus but uh
yeah um i i've seen no evidence that
columbus
knew of ibn batuta's writings um we know
that he read various other tales for
example
um the legend of the seven cities of
civolo was very important um
for um um columbus which is a story
about
see if i get this right a group of
bishops um
who um flees spain with
um muslim ships that have a lot of gold
they settle
on these uh mythic islands somewhere in
the sea
um and so you know various explorers
tried to find these islands and the gold
that they possessed
um again to fund a crusade or for any
other purpose
but i i i don't think columbus knew of
in batuta
sorry did you want to yes sure another
question submitted
from a participant a few years later
vasadagama is said to have been guided
from the east coast of africa
to india by arab sailors he found arab
merchants
in india when he landed how did he
negotiate
his relationship with these moors in
contrast to columbus
um that's a good question that i don't
i don't think i have a you know a full
answer to
other than to say you know vasco da gama
shared in a language of of of crusade as
much as
any of these other explorers um
he doesn't um yeah
but that's what i would answer to that
to that question i mean um
you know columbus also uses
um various arab sailing technologies
during his
voyages there's a complicated story
about the kind of sail
um that is used on the ships that he
takes across the atlantic that combined
um the technology of the dao which is an
indian ocean vessel that vasco da gama
used um but but you know in a general
way vasco da gama is
is is steeped in this same rhetoric
language
and education um of of crusade
um and is seeking right a way around the
muslim empires of the middle east as
much as any of these others are
there is a question um
regarding columbus's reasoning doesn't
the prevailing current contradict the
idea of wood
detritus floating east to west africa
okay i'm sorry could you repeat the
question so the question is
um doesn't the prevailing current
contradict the idea of
wood detritus floating from east to west
africa
oh right right i see what you're saying
um i guess it
does but it yeah i think the question
points to the fact that
that that notion of of wood floating
from across
um the ocean from asia is wrong that
wood was probably coming
from the port itself or from somewhere
further south on the coast or something
like that or maybe wasn't even worked by
human hands at all but when they looked
at it they thought it was
who knows right so then there's a
question that is a bit tricky to parse
but let me try
so um how would you describe your
positionality or your lens in this
research or book
i don't know they want you to frame your
political position your epistemic
position
i can answer that question i'm happy to
answer that question so um
i would say in this talk i
really turned up the volume on um
an idea of civilizational conflict
one that um historians have generally
been trying to get away from
um and i i admit that i wrestled with
that
um and i'll tell you a little bit about
why i decided
to keep it keep that language one is
that's the language of the sources
the sources the christian sources and
the muslim sources but
you know focusing here on columbus and
his writings and those of others
they use this language of civilizational
conflict of millennial confrontation
with um with islam columbus
spends the last few years of his life
writing um
a kind of compendia of um
ideas about the end times right um
he he very much is steeped in this
in this set of ideas um
around um conquest
warfare existential crisis
of christianity um so that's
i'm being true to the sources the other
sort of historiographical
i want to say move but challenge that
i'm putting
forth is the following so you know
historians of the mediterranean um
and of other cross cross cultural zones
if you like but the mediterranean is the
place where a lot of this work happens
have over the past few decades done a
lot of really important work
showing how um confessional boundaries
might not have been as fixed as we think
linguistic
boundaries um you know italian traitors
were living and and and and marrying
often
in the ottoman world muslims were in
europe there's there's this sense of
back and forth almost a kind of
happy-go-lucky
trading identities um religions
intermarriage language etc um
and that is obviously true to a point
i i think we we've over emphasized the
idea
that um and there are all kinds of
explanations for why we've done this
but we've over emphasized the idea that
something like religion
might not matter as much as we think it
does i think religion does matter quite
a lot
to these people in very stark and
important ways
geopolitically um theologically
um existentially um and so i want to
sort of reinsert that into the
discussion here um you know historians
have
and i've i've taught this work in my in
my courses have
to great effect use in the records of
the inquisition
you know obviously um a
endeavor of um religious violence
um to narrate other kinds of histories
right of commerce of
gender relations all kinds of things and
that's very very useful again
but um i think we have to understand
that the
the confessional um structure in which
much of this is taking place
and and and columbus's relationship with
the muslim world is one of the ways of
doing that but
it it does mean that you know in in some
ways for provocative purposes that i've
turned up
the volume more on the violent
competition warfare civilizational
crisis
but i'm i'm curious because um so that's
uh very interesting
but you know that reframing of the
modern conflict
um is not particularly productive right
so there's ferguson and these other
people who think
who are framing the current situation as
a clash of civilizations
do you do you believe that is actually
productive for the modern
kind of you know mirroring today's
struggle yeah yeah
no no no i mean and that and that's why
we as historians have tended to move
away from that
right um um nevertheless though
i would push back a little bit to say
not to you but to that to that work
to say that when you look at the history
of christianity
um there is there is an anti-islamic
thread that runs through
much of it right and it's pretty
consistent
or you know i don't let's say you know
we can argue about when
and and runs deep you're right it runs
very deep right and it ebbs and flows
over time etc
and i think i think we need to we need
to wrestle with that and take that
seriously and understand why that can
look there's been a lot of work done on
anti-semitism the long history of
anti-semitism from
antiquity even before christianity right
from antiquity
to the present you know there's a whole
set of books there's been some
on you know an equivalent sort of story
about islam in
christian thought but i think there's a
lot more work that could be
done there so yes i wrestled with not
wanting to tell the kind of
clash of civilization stories that
muslims and christians have been
fighting
for all time everywhere always and yet
pretty consistently at least from the
period that i know best
right the kind of late medieval to the
present um that
if you look at various periods of
christian writing and thought
i'm talking about european christianity
here um you do see that there is a
pretty consistent trend
of anti-muslim sentiments
um writing about the theological
bankruptcy of islam
talking about um um the political
corruption of of islam
et cetera so that story needs to be told
i'm not doing that here but but but that
balance has to be kept in play of not
doing the crude version of clash of
civilizations but nevertheless
seeing that there that there is a story
here
so the next question is um
from um a member of the audience what i
heard of muslim influence on columbus is
that
muslim sources had the best figure for
the circumference of the earth
to find uh the qibla but they were
expressed in arab miles rather than the
shorter roman miles
used in europe columbus used good
figures but with the wrong
interpretation to argue that the voyage
was shorter
yeah i mean i i i haven't gone deep in
on that line on columbus look when you
get into the columbus scholarship it
goes in all kinds of directions
there's also issues of maps i remember
reading that there
there were incorrect maps that um yeah
so then the follow-up question is genoa
had colonies in the crimea as you
pointed out
so i'm surprised that there was so such
inaccurate information
uh on the mongol on the mongols there
was no great khan by then
well so the the idea of the of the great
khan
um many historians think is based in
some
fact um that being that the nestorian
christians
of western china um so there is evidence
that
um during the yuan period uh that there
were
um um uh people who converted to
christianity
um and um that that might have been one
of the
the reference for the idea of the
great khan having an interest in
christianity so there's an interesting
question
um is there evidence that when cortes
and others went back from the americas
that they took with them some of the
people they had conquered
and if so were these individuals
distributed by
them in north africa or in europe
you mean native peoples yeah native
peoples yeah
yeah no native peoples go back with
columbus and
and and you know on after that that's a
quite common thing
for um on various european expeditions
for
um native peoples to go back to europe
um not back but go to europe um and then
sometimes back to the americas
and some but sometimes not also
wait um
hi do you see any further questions no i
don't i think we got them all
yeah can i just follow up my question
the cortez question
about the native people so were those
people
a similar force to assimilate into
christianity or
islam or well it depends
what you know who we're talking about
because no since
since you mentioned that they were
perceived as
a muslim right no no i mean
so usually when native peoples come are
brought to
europe they are sort of displayed as
um as um spectacles to be seen
in cities yeah um and any any kind
of religious conversion that they would
have
um um experienced or
had forced upon them um was to
christianity not to islam
okay thank you so um
thank you so much alan for this
wonderful talk and
answering the vigorous q a
and thanks everyone for attending and
look forward to seeing you all at the
next frankie event
thank you very much thank you